kollegen der weit überwiegende teil
dieses hauses wird bei der beschreibung
der lage übereinstimme
sie ist ernst das zeigen uns die
infektionszahlen habe ich gestern bei
der leitung der charité noch einmal
unterrichten lassen darüber welche
entwicklungen auf den intensivstationen
zu beklagen ist
es hilft auch nichts dass wir uns in
deutschland vergleichen mit london wo es
in dieser woche eröffnungs schritt bei
der gastronomie und im handel gegeben
hat es macht auch keinen sinn zu
beklagen welche managementfehler es in
den vergangenen monaten seitens der
politik gegeben hat das hilft uns in
dieser situation jetzt nicht
es muss nun schnell wirksam und
rechtssicher gehandelt werden wirksame
maßnahmen sind die masken pflicht eine
wirksame maßnahme ist die begrenzung der
kontakte der haushalte eine wirksame
maßnahme ist eine test strategie der
fingerzeig auf die wirtschaft ersetzt
eine solche test strategie indes nicht
angesichts der soziodemographie der
schwererkrankten empfiehlt sich eine
gesundheitliche aufklärung auch nicht
nur in der deutschen sprache und vor
allem müssen wir das tempo beim impfen
erhöhen
durch den einsatz alle reserven durch
die zeitliche streckung zwischen erst
und zweitens und durch die einbeziehung
des gesamten niedergelassenen bereichs
schnelle wirksame und rechtssichere
maßnahmen stehen wir uns stehen uns zur
verfügung
der jetzige gesetzentwurf ist ja eine
reaktion auf das scheitern der
sogenannten oster uhr es ist richtig
dass nun bundeseinheitlich gehandelt
wird meine fraktion hat
bundeseinheitliche wenn dann regeln
bekanntlich im dezember vorgeschlagen
hier in diesem gesetzentwurf gibt es
allerdings nur eine
nicht differenzierter regel für das
ganze bundesgebiet es ist im übrigen
auch richtig den deutschen bundestag zu
beteiligen und nicht ausschließlich nur
auf die bund länder runde der
regierungschefin und regierungschefs zu
setzen
und trotzdem nimmt es wunder dass es nun
gar keine beteiligung der länder mehr
geben soll
es hätte sie ergeben können der
nordrhein westfälische ministerpräsident
hat sie ja sogar ein vorziehen der bund
länder runde vorgeschlagen
am montag wäre sie regulär gewesen und
nun gibt es keine ich glaube dass das
die falschen konsequenzen aus dem
scheitern der oster hohe sind frau
bundeskanzlerin auch im verfahren im
kern dieser sogenannten bundes notbremse
das ging aus dem beitrag der
bundeskanzlerin und auch der kollegin
der spd hervor im kern steht nun die
ausgangs bremse ausgangssperre dieser
notbremse
in der praxis bedeutet das dass ein
geimpftes ehepaar aufgrund eines eines
ausspruchs kilometerweit entfernt in
einem einzelnen betrieb daran gehindert
wird alleine nach 21 uhr vor die tür zu
treten zum abendspaziergang und diesen
einen praktischen beispiel diesem
lebenssachverhalt drückt sich die ganze
im übrigen auch verfassungsrechtliche
problematik aus keine unterscheidung
zwischen geimpften und nicht geimpften
keine differenzierte bewertung
desinfektions geschehens cluster
ausbruch oder diffus keine anderen
parameter deshalb ja die praktikerinnen
und praktiker des landkreistages so
vehement gegen diese regelung
protestiert haben und im übrigen auch
die die sind immer gegen alles erbringt
haus das ist nun ein misstrauensvotum
gegenüber der kommunalen ebene dass sie
gerade zum ausdruck gebracht haben und
im
auch eine umstrittene wirksamkeit der
maßnahme der wissenschaftliche beirat
der französischen regierung hat die dort
ja über zwei monate ab 18 uhr
bestehenden ausgangssperren
wissenschaftlich evaluieren lassen mit
dem ergebnis dass sie eben keinen
beitrag zur begrenzung der infektionen
geleistet haben und aus diesem grund aus
diesem grund ist das was sie zur
ausgangssperre hier regeln wollen hoch
problematisch wir werden ihnen
vorschläge machen
dieses gesetz verfassungsfest zu machen
sollten sie diese entschuldigen sie
bitte herr kollege brinkhaus in dieser
situation verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
an zu machen die wir das tun das sollten
sie eher schätzen denn sie können kein
interesse daran haben dass dieses gesetz
am ende weil sie auf keinen hinweis
eingehen in karlsruhe gescheitert
der schaden für das vertrauen in die
pandemie politik insgesamt wäre immens
wenn sie verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
nicht ernst nehmen wir werden es ist
überhaupt nicht nur diskutieren bringt
herr kollege brinkhaus herr kollege
brinkhaus die art und weise wie sie hier
argumentieren spricht eigentlich für
sich
und im übrigen im übrigen will ich sagen
will ich sagen dass ben wenn sie auf
diese bedenken ja nicht nur von uns
vorgetragen werden nicht eingehen wir
uns gezwungen sehen
aus der fdp fraktion den weg nach
karlsruhe im wege von
verfassungsbeschwerden zu gehen
diese
ausgangs beschränkung ist im übrigen
nicht nur verfassungsrechtlich
hochproblematisch
der kollege lauterbach hat gestern wie
ich glaube realistischerweise darauf
hingewiesen dass aufgrund der hunderter
inzidenz und der art und weise wie diese
notbremse nun automatisch ausgelöst
werden soll
an vielen stellen über viele wochen es
zu einer ausgangssperre kommen könnte
und da muss man unterscheiden zwischen
denjenigen die die einen komfortablen
wohnverhältnissen sind aber was ist denn
mit den studierenden im ein zimmer
appartement was ist denn mit der familie
wie ohne balken der etagenwohnung auf
engerem raum zusammenlebt die werden
dann möglicherweise in herr lauterbach
prognose recht hat über wochen in den
räumen sein während es draußen bereits
hell ist und das ist ein enormer
sozialer schaden der damit verbunden ist
im übrigen herr kollege bringt kauf
nehmen sie doch bitte zur kenntnis sie
haben jetzt ja gestrichen in ihrem
gesetzentwurf die möglichkeit des tests
basieren öffnung des basierten öffnen
der vorsitzende des teams vorsicht der
bayerische ministerpräsident wer hat am
9 april siebten april mit seinem
landeskabinett noch beschlossen dass
zwischen der hunderter und 200h
incidents termin shopping mit test
möglich ist
ab der 200er incidents ist dort immer
noch handel möglich nach dem modell
click and collect das sagt der
vorsitzende des teams vorsicht und
verehrte anwesende liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das könnte dafür sprechen
entweder ist es eine frage des
politischen charakters oder es könnte
dafür sprechen dass vom handel ohne
kontakt tatsächlich kein
infektionsrisiko ausgeht ich neige der
zweiten etappe
aktion zu liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das debakel der oster ruhe darf sich
nicht wiederholen
und deshalb ist mein appell an die
regierungsfraktionen nehmen sie die aus
den ländern aus der rechtswissenschaft
von praktikern und auch aus dem
parlament vorgetragenen
verfassungsrechtlichen bedenken ernst
machen sie es sich bitte nicht so leicht
wie der kollege brinkhaus christian
lindner der fraktionschef der fdp
fraktion und was die experten sagen
übrigens zu diesem gesetzentwurf das
wird sich heute nachmittag schon zeigen
denn da gibt es schon eine öffentliche
expertenanhörung zu dem gesetzentwurf
lauterbach ist von christian lindner ja
angesprochen worden
herr präsident meine kolleginnen und
kollegen zunächst einmal erlebt sie
haben mich richtig zitiert aber nicht
vollständig zitiert und das ist in
diesem zusammenhang ist es bedeutsam ich
habe darauf hingewiesen womit sie recht
haben dass wir in sehr vielen
landkreisen eine inzidenz von unter 100
nicht erreichen werden dann würde die
notbremse mit den ausgangs
beschränkungen gelten sowie von ihnen
vorgetragen
ich habe aber auch darauf hingewiesen
dass es nicht so sein muss weil wir
andere maßnahme greifen können und
müssen
und aus meiner sicht wäre es fair
gewesen dass dazu zu hören da ich haben
dafür gestern noch konkrete beispiele
gebracht es wäre auch an ihnen gewesen
entsprechende beispiele heute
vorzutragen
die habe ich aber die habe ich nicht
vernommen ich bin mit ihnen einer
meinung dass wir die intervalle strecken
könnten das ist aber auch der punkt so
bei einer meinung sind
aber mit dieser haltung dass wir uns
hier gegenseitig kompliziert erklären
was alles in deutschland nicht
funktioniere
was aber in aus nicht nur funktioniert
hat sondern auch gewirkt hat womit man
dort die wellen brechen konnte womit man
dort auf insolvenzen unter 30
mittlerweile gekommen ist mit dieser
debatte kommen wir nicht weiter wir
brauchen pragmatismus und keine
gegenseitige aufklären was alles nicht
funktioniert daher bitte ich dass wir
tatsächlich in dieser ausgangssperre
eine notwendige aber nicht hinreichende
maßnahme sehen
es wird allein nicht reichen aber in
keinem land in keinem land ist es
gelungen eine welle mit an der b17
mutation nochmal in den griff zu
bekommen ohne dass man nicht auch und
nicht alleine ohne dass man nicht auch
das instrument der ausgangs
beschränkungen und nicht sperren genutzt
hätte herr kollege lindner bisher sie
können ja wieder herr präsident der
kollege lauter war tatsächlich habe ich
hier eben das können sie im protokoll ja
noch einmal nach seiner reihe von
vorschlägen gemacht sprach von masken
pflicht begrenzung der kontakte der
haushalte test strategie aufklärung auch
in fremdsprachen und beschleunigung des
im übrigens zur ausgangssperre
eine solche ausgangssperre ist auch
schon von gesundheitsministern der fdp
begrüßt worden nämlich in flensburg wo
eine sozialdemokratische
oberbürgermeisterin zusammen mit unserem
fdp-gesundheitsminister bei einem
diffusen infektionsgeschehen bei noch
nicht großen fortschritt zu anfang
dieses jahres sich zu diesem instrument
genötigt sah also insofern da sind wir
nicht paniert aber so wie sie es hier in
das gesetz schreiben wollen ist es eben
unverhältnismäßig und lassen sie mich
hinzufügen denn wenn sie schon mangelnde
vollständigkeit beklagen zwar bei mir
keine absicht hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass sie wenn sich schon die wirksamkeit
der ausgangssperre gerade noch einmal
unterstrichen hätten dass sie
eingegangen wären auf die
wissenschaftliche untersuchung des
beirats der französischen regierung die
in frage gestellt haben auf einer
breiten datenbasis zwei monate ab 18 uhr
ob nicht gar eine negative wirkung von
der ausgangssperre ausgeht aufgrund der
verdichtung von kontakten
[Applaus]